[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 13 février
bienvenue dans le cetud journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition la manifestation cet après midi
des professeurs devant les locaux de la
direction académique à guyancourt une
cinquantaine de personnes s'est
rassemblée à l'appel du syndicat snes
fsu des yvelines en cause la baisse de
la dotation horaire dans les
établissements qui entraînerait
notamment des fermetures de postes
d'après l'éducation nationale au moins
un collégien sur cinq est concerné par
les cyber violences notamment le
harcèlement en ligne pour sensibiliser
les adolescents la gendarmerie des
yvelines a lancé protect une application
ludique sur le sujet expérimenté dans le
département elle nous en parlons avec le
colonel loïc barras enfin la marque a
été créée en 1955 qui a repris sa
production en 2017 le constructeur
automobile alpine investi hier l'estac à
une conférence était organisée à l'école
d'ingénieurs de montigny le bretonneux
spécialisée dans l'e mobilité est deux
véhicules ont pris place dans
l'auditorium
et puis nous recevrons également sur ce
plateau l'école tu as dragon bleu à
l'initiative du nouvel an chinois à
verneuil sur seine qui est célébré ce
week end ils sont déjà inquiets pour la
rentrée prochaine des professeurs ont
manifesté devant la direction
départementale de l'éducation nationale
à guyancourt ces enseignants conteste la
dotation horaire attribuée pour la
rentrée qui engendrerait selon les
syndicats des suppressions de postes
d'options mais aussi des classes
surchargées
elle les précisions de manon varaldo
stop mépris lycée en colère voici les
messages que proclament les
contestataires sur les banderoles
déployées devant le ds dn la direction
des services départementaux de
l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui on est sur une mobilisation
dans le cadre de la préparation rentrée
2010 neuf donc les moyens pour faire
fonctionner les établissements à la
rentrée sont arrivés dans les
établissements et donc les
les personnes qui sont rassemblés
derrière moi et qui se manifestent sont
là pour réclamer davantage de moyens
pour préparer leur rentrée professeurs
et parents inquiets de la dotation
horaire globale
ce nombre d'heures d'enseignement
attribué par établissement qui sert à
réaliser la répartition des classes
cette année la dotation horaire globale
qui a été allouée a été diminué ce qui
fait que classe va être supprimé je
pense qu'on n'a pas même enseignement
canton et 26 élèves dans une classe où
quand on est 31 32
l'enseignant ne peut pas avoir la même
attention avec tous les élèves et est
bon ça devient des enseignements plus
difficile motivée non résigné les
enseignants déplorent la dégradation des
conditions d'enseignement et veulent le
faire entendre aux représentants de la
déesse des yens ce qui risque de
disparaître en tout cas dé diminuer ses
les dispositifs d'être qui sont
proposées aux élèves en terme de
dédoublement par exemple pour les
matières expérimentales ou des
dédoublements avec des groupes de
besoins dans mathématiques en français
on pourra certainement proposer moins
que ce qu'on propose aujourd'hui
l'insuffisance des dotations se
manifeste également par des suppressions
de postes pour le département des
yvelines on estime que c'est environ une
trentaine de postes à peu près 13 13 en
collège et aux 18 ans lycée naf
établissements demandé à être reçus par
la direction des services départementaux
de l'éducation nationale en fin d'après
midi les enseignants envisagent d'autres
actions avec le soutien des parents il
ya une délégation d'enseignants a été
reçue cet après midi par la direction
académique autre mouvement celui des
pompiers des yvelines une cinquantaine
d'entre eux s'est réuni hier à
versailles au moment de la tenue du
conseil d'administration du service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
ils ont voulu alerter sur leurs
conditions de travail lé syndicat de la
profession dénonce un manque d'effectif
face à un nombre grandissant et
d'intervention il manquerait 129 postes
pour assurer convenablement est la
sécurité de la population selon les
syndicats on a appris aujourd'hui cette
opération réussie mené conjointement par
le commissariat de plaisir et la spa le
24 janvier dernier les policiers ont
sauvé sept chiens maltraités par des
gens du voyage installés sur la commune
ces animaux étaient attachés à des
chaînes courtes sans eau est mal nourrie
son couchage et avec pour seul abri une
petite niche ils ont été ensuite
recueillis par la spa de plaisir vous
voyez à l'image est la spa qui a porté
plainte cinq personnes ont été entendues
dans cette affaire transmise au parquet
de versailles
et depuis déjà trois des sept chiens ont
retrouvé deux nouvelles familles on vous
parlait hier dans ce journal des écrans
de la multiplication des écrans dans la
vie à des enfants les jeunes qui sont
également confrontés aux dangers
d'internet et des réseaux sociaux
contenu explicite harcèlement en ligne
au moins un collégien sur cinq serait
par exemple
confronté aux cyber violences d'après
l'éducation nationale bonsoir colonel
luc barras bonsoir d'être le commandant
de groupement de gendarmerie des
yvelines et vous avez lancé protect un
dispositif pour sensibiliser les jeunes
à ces thématiques du des cyber violence
et qui est en expérimentation
actuellement sur le territoire on vous
en parlait déjà quels sont ces menaces
numérique est ce qu elles sont
nombreuses alors le cyberespace
c'est comme dans le monde réel un
endroit où les jeunes peuvent rencontrer
des problèmes voire des infractions
pénales donc ces risques qui sont
nombreux et ils sont parfois amplifiée
par un certain anonymat sur les réseaux
sociaux et la viralité des réseaux et
aujourd'hui les enjeux face à justement
à ces menaces qu'elles sont il bat les
enjeux cd enjeu d'éducation un l'idée
c'est que chaque jeune puisse naviguer
en toute tranquillité et en toute
sécurité dans le cyberespace comme il le
fait dans la voie publique dans la rue
tous les jours on a compris en danger
auprès des jeunes est ce qu'il n'ya pas
aussi un enjeu auprès des parents qui
sont peut-être aussi mal formés sur sur
ces risques liés au numérique aux
réseaux sociaux et à l'internet à il est
sûr que aujourd'hui pour forcir le trait
c'est plus internet qui éduque que
l'école où les parents en étant un peu
provocateur
c'est vrai que l'enjeu d'éducation des
parents est majeur et souvent on a des
parents qui sont un peu démuni devant
des applications des réseaux sociaux qui
ne comprennent pas en fait
et du coup la gendarmerie des yvelines
et est pleinement mobilisé vous
intervenez souvent auprès d'écoliers de
collégiens c'est ça alors pour faire de
la cyber prévention nous on intervient
comme la police nationale où certaines
polices municipales à différents niveaux
dont
le collège mais également les écoles
primaires parce que on commence très
jeune
normalement enfin en général un enfant
commence vers 9 ans à naviguer sur
internet
les études qui le montre donc on a une
action très forte dans les classes de
cm2 à l'aide du permis internet qui
permet de donner un peu les clés de
prudence de compréhension à un enfant de
cm2 de pour naviguer tranquillement sur
internet et donc à côté de cet outil du
permis à internet vous expérimentez dans
les yvelines
actuellement l'application protect c'est
une initiative de la gendarmerie des
yvelines développé avec l'association
e-enfance pourquoi être initiateurs sur
ce thème
alors va déjà la mission de prévention
de la cyber prévention c'est une mission
de la gendarmerie
et moi j'ai souhaité que nous disposions
d'outils pédagogiques un peu rénové
moderne innovant et qui parle aux
enfants c'est à dire que concrètement on
a des groupes d'enfants de 6e qui vont
être mis sur des actions de
sensibilisation de deux heures avec un
intervenant est également des tablettes
numériques et quel est le principe
comment ça fonctionne protect alors
protect c'est de la cyber tranquillité
et on utilise les ressorts du jeu c'est
à dire de la surprise de la mise en
situation et on va s'y voulait réveiller
un peu les émotions des adolescents
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir trois grands
thèmes qui sont les thèmes les plus
courants qu'on rencontre sur dans les
dépôts de plainte et dans les problèmes
que rencontrent les jeunes c'est la
protection des données personnelles
le cyber harcèlement et le phénomène des
fake news et les avantages pour les
jeunes à utiliser cette application
quels sont ils alors les avantages c'est
justement de prévenir tous les aléas des
réseaux sociaux et de ne pas se
retrouver dans des situations où on est
obligé de faire un défi le mode
challenge par exemple dangereux pour soi
même qu'on va diffuser ou alors pour une
jeune fille de se faire cybers harceler
avec une un chantage à la clé parce que
elle a posé de manière dénuder devant
son petit copain qui la menace de
diffuser les informations sur le
déploiement on en est à une phase
d'expérimentation en ce moment
c'est ça oui tout à fait donc là
l'application elle est finalisée avec
l'association e-enfance nous avons eu
des supports de différents mécènes et
sponsors et maintenant nous sommes dans
une phase en fait de formation des
formateurs et d'ici le mois de juin
l'ambition c'est de former l'ensemble
des classes de 6e pour six
établissements scolaires donc 3 pour
l'agent mari et trois points police
nationale donc c'est uniquement sur un
public scolaire ça pourrait être étendue
après cette phase d'expérimentation ce
alors le questionnant l'idée c'est
vraiment de s'adresser aux élèves de
sixième lorsque la sixième c'est la
classe pour laquelle les enfants sont
équipées de tablettes de smartphones et
c'est là qu'ils font vraiment leurs
premiers pas dans les réseaux sociaux un
dernier mot sur les attentes quelles
sont elles
autour de cette application les attentes
sont fortes parce que c'est un beau
projet c'est un projet qui s'il donne
satisfaction sera étendu à l'ensemble
des collèges yvelinois pour la rentrée
prochaine et sera proposé également à
d'autres départements
merci colonel loïc basse d'être passé
sur ce plateau commandant du groupement
de gendarmerie des yvelines et on
retrouve d'ailleurs l'actualité de la
gendarmerie des yvelines notamment sur
son compte twitter qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran
elle déteste des conseils des
informations détaillées lors de la
nouvelle édition de la nuit des métiers
l'orientation elle vient de se tenir à
montigny le bretonneux alors que les
élèves sont en pleine réflexion sur leur
avenir professionnel retour avec
marylène iapichino et wilfrid richy un
jeune sur deux douteraient de ses
compétences pour réussir son parcours si
l'on en croit le dernier sondage
opinionway dévoilé la semaine dernière
un sondage qui révèle aussi que les
parents ne sont pas toujours d'un grand
secours pour faire les bons choix
d'orientation ya 30 40 ans nos parents
et grands parents
choisissez un métier épousé sa
généralement quasiment toute leur vie
on sait aujourd'hui que une grande
partie de ces jeunes exerceront un
meetic est totalement inconnu à ce jour
on parle de plus de 50% de métiers qui
vont se créer ça veut dire que d'autres
vont mourir donc ça veut dire que
certains se questionnent sur comment
bien se préparer à l'évolution du monde
dans lequel on évolue aujourd'hui
cette année la nuit des métiers de
montigny le bretonneux a donc ouvert ses
portes aux étudiants pour évoquer leur
parcours à leurs cadets cette mère a
échangé avec une étudiante en médecine
on a échangé la première année de
médecine donc leur ressenti savoir au
niveau de l'intensité des cours
ben ce que ça représentait donc
voilà qui est hésitant aujourd'hui ça
lui permettra de d'avoir déjà davantage
d'informations sur le sujet mais c'est
bien la réforme du bac et la disparition
des filières traditionnelles qui suscite
le plus d'inquiétude si l'on en croit
les parents présents à des changements
encore faim sachs les options mais
disons qu'on a les tenants n'en a pas
forcément les aboutissants les chemins
pour y aller tant que ça c'est encore
mon investigation complète dès l'an
prochain les lycéens choisiront des
spécialités afin de mieux appréhender
l'enseignement supérieur d'où
l'importance de faire les meilleurs
choix
enfin le pôle jeunesse a aussi présenté
des solutions alternatives aux jeunes en
rupture de scolarité du service civique
à la mobilité européenne est si vous
avez manqué ce rendez vous il est
possible de venir se renseigner tout au
long de l'année à guyancourt le stade du
gymnase de l'aviation a accueilli des
matches de foot de football un peu
particulier sur le terrain pas de joueur
professionnel mais une dizaine de
recruteurs et une quinzaine de
demandeurs d'emploi yvelinois c'est l'
agence départementale d'insertion
activity qui a lancé cette
expérimentation l'objectif c'est de
mettre en valeur les compétences
comportementales plutôt que les
expériences professionnelles un moyen de
recruter plus dynamique et moins
traditionnelle interview collectées par
au rayon insolite original mais c'est
plutôt agréable après pour nous c'était
une première fois je pense que c'est
quelque chose à reconduire effectivement
parce que on a rarement l'occasion
finalement de rencontrer plusieurs
profils en une seule fois et on va là ça
commençait par un jeune qui vient de se
présenter à nous j'ai essayé de me
présenter au mieux
donc on a moins d'insérer leurs propres
et bien sûr donc aulas et l'entreprise
où c'est assez structuré qu'on connaît
qui tiennent debout depuis longtemps
donc oui donc moi j'ai dit mes quatre
vérités donc puis je l'aurais fourni mon
cv
et puis par la suite
pourquoi pas envers un des deux autres
matchs de football devrait être
organisée au cours du premier semestre
2010 9
c'était l'évènement ce mardi soir à
l'école d'ingénieurs de l'estac à une
conférence était organisée sur le thème
à deux constructeurs automobiles alpine
une marque créée en 1955 qui a vu sa
production en reprendre officiellement
fin 2017 et les étudiants ont pu
notamment voir deux voitures dans
l'auditorium mais aussi échanger avec
les professionnels un reportage de
michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans cette école
d'ingénieurs les stars se sont elles
deux alpes et d'installer de façon
éphémère dans cet auditorium de l'estaca
les voitures alpine franchement je suis
étonnée elle son sens vachement belle
elle est magnifique mais des super belle
ligne une belle couleur bien à créer
c'est la fierté française que c'est
ça fait plaisir de voir des belles
sportives les deux véhicules ont été
installés dans le cadre d'une conférence
sur l'univers de la marque une première
pour l'école au programme l'histoire de
l'entreprise fondée en 1955 et sa
renaissance depuis 2015 l'objectif c'est
de susciter les vocations mais pas
seulement je pense que les étudiants qui
ont choisi la filière automobile à
l'estaca sont déjà des gens passionnés
et enthousiastes pour le métier de
l'autoroute pour les métiers de
l'automobile
pour nous ce qui est avant tout
principal moteur c'est véritablement de
de partager notre passion pour alpiq
les deux professionnels sont également
allés à la rencontre des étudiants
pendant près d'une heure pour partager
leur expérience dans le monde de
l'automobile et découvrir les différents
projets de l'école ça fait plaisir ça
manque quand on s'intéresse à l'école
que ça une renommée déjà et que du coup
on voit que l'école est présente dans
tous les milieux et l'estaca à une
certaine reid certaines côtes qui sont
du métier est vrai que ça fait rêver ça
nous donne envie de forcément de faire
le même métier dans les mêmes boîtes ça
nous donne enfin un aperçu de notre
futur métier d'ingénieur saidal envie de
de poursuivre juste ans jusqu'en
cinquième année l'histoire entre l'estac
à la marque alpine n'est peut-être pas
encore terminé de nouvelles conférences
pourraient être organisées dans les
prochaines années
au plus grand bonheur des étudiants est
encore dans la thématique de
l'automobile usines psa de poissy
produira-t-elle le prochain véhicule
électrique du groupe le site aux 3000
salariés en tout cas est candidate et
auprès de sa direction pour remporter le
marché qui est garanti ray des emplois à
long terme un investissement de 100
millions d'euros est nécessaire pour
moderniser les chaînes de production
une partie pourrait être prise en charge
par le département et la région la
décision sera connue dans les prochaines
semaines depuis le 5 février c'est le
nouvel an chinois depuis une semaine on
célèbre l'année du cochon de terre mais
le plus gros des festivités c'est ce
week-end les yvelines aussi fêteront
cette nouvelle année du calendrier
chinois à verneuil-sur-seine deux
invités autour de cette table pour en
parler
frédéric collet bonsoir bonsoir et
jean-marie bourreau bonsoir on sera
alors vous êtes respectivement président
et membre de
de l'école du dragon bleu vous qu
organiser ce nouvel an chinois à
verneuil avec la ville et les
commerçants alors avant de présenter
l'événement un mot sur le dragon bleu
vous enseigner les arts martiaux chinois
et le kung fu traditionnelle et on parle
bien des cols et et non pas de club
la nuance est importante oui comme en
celle enchaîne le kung-fu s'apprend dans
des écoles c'est didactique on la prend
comme la géographie ou l'histoire
sauf qu'on cultive son physique donc ça
revient un petit peu à la culture
physique dans le temps qui a disparu au
profit du sport donc culture physique de
base le kung-fu c'est d'abord la santé
ensuite l'éducation des jeunes
et puis ensuite garder la santé quand on
est plus grand quand on est adulte
bien sûr ça comporte la une grosse
partie de combat l'école et nés en 97
elle a 22 ans maintenant elles étaient
fondées donc là verneuil sur seine qui
nous a accueillis à bras ouverts et on
est très très heureux qu'ils aient ces
trois présentations chinoise au sein de
la ville ne peut être pas que la
pratique sportive c'est plus globale
c'est beaucoup plus globale oui puisque
ça va de 6 ans jusqu'à fin de vie
puisque après il ya les arts internes le
tai chi chuan qui permet de conserver la
santé le tchi kong tout ça ce sont les
arts asiatiques les chinois ont une
réponse à chaque moment de la vie
il y a une réponse physique pour
conserver la santé
certains en chine c'était primordial ne
pas avoir la santé s'est de plus pouvoir
travailler
donc ce n'est plus vivre et cet
événement du nouvel an chinois pourquoi
il est important pour vous finalement de
parler de ce moment de la culture
chinoise moment important qui est pas
forcément connus on connaît pas toutes
les significations de ce moment
justement vous utilisez les bons termes
une école de culture chinoise à verneuil
sur seine ont l'année dernière on a
initié la première édition de ce nouvel
an chinois pour justement essayer de
faire découvrir à la population de
verneuil cet événement ça a été un
succès on a eu plus de 400 spectateurs
sur les deux les deux événements qu'ont
organisé cela n'est rien et donc cette
année on repart pour une deuxième
édition est encore bull juste avant une
semaine avant vous étiez à l'hippodrome
de vincennes pour le nouvel an chinois
des festivités du nouvel an chinois au
cices oui on a été donc l'école a été
sélectionné par l'hippodrome de
vincennes pour l'ouverture basse que l'
hippodrome en fête est très lié avec la
chine et donc on a fait
on a fait cette ouverture de l'année
lunaire du nouvel an chinois on a été
donc invité puisqu'on a dragon et lyon
chinois qui sont les symboles vraiment
du nouvel an chinois
ce nouvel an effectivement il a une date
astronomique on va dire et puis ensuite
il ya quinze jours de festivités et donc
pendant ces quinze jours de festivités
on a profité d'être cet hippodrome en
compagnie de miss france 2010 neuf donc
c'était une journée extraordinaire un
bel événement alors qu organisé donc ce
nouvel an chinois verneuil depuis deux
ans maintenant ça va être la deuxième
édition
racontez nous un peu comment s'est monté
ce projet comment il a été rendue
possible dans cette ville de verneuil
par rapport à la première édition on a
eu la chance d'avoir l'équipe municipale
de verneuil et patricia hewitt l'adjoint
en charge de la communication des
événements qui s'est rapproché nous pour
essayer de maximiser la première édition
donc cette année on part en partenariat
avec la ville de verneuil avec
l'association des commerçants et des
artisans de verneuil et l'école du
dragon bleu pour faire de cet événement
un événement encore plus symbolique et
on veut l'ancré dans le paysage
la ville de verneuil a pour principe de
créer une synergie autour des
manifestations dans le centre ville pour
favoriser les le lien social le tissu
associatif
l'intergénérationnel on a plusieurs
événements symboliques à verneuil on a
les fêtes de verneuil mois de juin
l'halloween les fêtes de noël et donc du
coup pour associer aux paysages ce ce
nouvel an chinois qu'on espère pouvoir
installer pour le long terme
oui c'était une évidence de leur
proposer cette année vous le dites une
installée sur le long terme ça c'est
l'objectif c'est l'objectif c'est la
réflexion a déjà mené pour l'année
prochaine pour voir si on peut pas
l'augmenter en termes de de festivités
d'interactivité on voit dans les
yvelines ya d'autres villes qui créent
leur événement on a été un peu
précurseur l'année dernière on souhaite
installer fortement cet événement dans
le paysage local
non juste avant de présenter le
programme un cortège est prévu bien sûr
avec des lions et dragons de lumière ça
demande beaucoup de préparation on
imagine sa demande énormément de
préparation en amont on a commencé au
mois d'octobre a préparé ça en fait
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en chine
ce sont les écoles de kung fu qu'on
appelle parce que c'est très sportif
manipuler
ils ont manipulé les dragons faire des
cascades dans la rue ça demande
énormément de qualités sportives donc on
demande en chine aux écoles de kung fu
qui viennent un petit peu qui sont
vraiment les personnes sollicitées en
priorité donc là il va y avoir un
cortège qui va partir d'une partie de la
ville qui va traverser toute la ville
déjà dans un premier temps et qui va
arriver au centre-ville au clos du
verger vers 18h le soir où ce sera un
peu le point d'orgue de la manifestation
est alors suffi d'elle à la tradition on
passe devant chaque commerce qui c'est
qui a mis des décorations sur dans ses
vitrines on vient apporter la prospérité
la chance pour la nouvelle année comme
disent les chinois c'est pas une hyène
païenne qui veut dire la nouvelle année
plus le soir on va enchaîner donc il y
aura des stands des buffets il va y
avoir de la nourriture il va y avoir des
boissons etc
donc on va vivre vraiment à l'heure
chinoise un petit peu comme ça se passe
en chine dans un village chinois
sauf que là ce sera à verneuil sur seine
et puis des cascades des démonstrations
kung fu tai-chi une petite surprise à la
fin parce qu'en fait on va voir arriver
une divinité maléfique qui à l'époque
des centaines et montagne pour manger
les enfants et elle va venir en vrai à
verneuil le soir mais heureusement il ya
des élèves de kung fu qui vont chasser
le méchant et vous y ajouter quelque
chose dans l'humour ça sera le mot de la
fin
l on parle de l'école de kung fu méo
faut voir aussi qu'on a les écoles de la
ville qui se sont associés à la
manifestation n'a une dizaine de classes
peu près 300 enfants qui ont appris un
champ en mandarin et qu'ils ont qui
créent eux mêmes leurs petits masques
qui porteront pour un côté un peu festif
est donc le nouvel an chinois avec
verneuil sur seine c'est ce samedi
rendez vous à partir de 17 heures dans
la zone commerciale c'est ça on peut
donner leur vie cette zone commerciale
de maupas 18h clos du verger centre
ville de berne et toutes les
informations sur les sites internet qui
sont affichés merci à vous deux frédéric
malet président et jean marie moreau
membre de l'école du dragon bleu
merci à vous pour refermer ce journal le
départ de ce rallye raid automobile
mythique est programmée le 21 février le
4l trophy 2010 9 s'élancera de biarritz
direction le maroc 2600 les étudiants
attendus notamment deux plaisirs wars
rencontre signé michael et demi d'euros
séance studieuse pour marianne et justin
les deux étudiants de 21 ans originaire
de plaisir ne sont pas en train de
réviser leurs cours mais de préparer le
4l trophy un raid étudiant solidaire
entre la france et le maroc au départ de
biarritz au programme des 6000 km pistes
désertiques d'une réorientation à la
boussole c'est une expérience je pense
que on voit en apprendre beaucoup de
cette aventure notamment au lieu au
niveau humain c'est par exemple il ya
des gens qui sont en galère ' on se voit
on peut s'arrêter et demander qu'est ce
qui se passe pour aider quoi c'est une
belle façon de découvrir le maroc et je
pensais à une aventure inoubliable
j'espère qu'on n'aura pas trop de
galères sur la route pour ne pas avoir
trop de problèmes sur les chemins en
sable et les deux plaisirs oise ont
testé leurs voitures sur les routes du
département depuis son acquisition l'été
dernier les sportives ont également reçu
des cours de mécanique de la part d'un
garagiste local
tous les jours on va devoir checker le
filtre à air parce que avec le sable il
sera en sable et du coup il va falloir
ouvrir cette petite boîte là et du coup
à l'intérieur il ya le frère on a une
machine du coup qui va souffler pour
rooter rythme stable
moi je me sens pas de calais aux
mécaniques mais bon on connaît les
petites bases et franchement on a un
mécano super au top qui est super
passionnés du coup par les vieilles
voitures donc sûr que la voiture allait
aller en état pour partir aujourd'hui
ces deux têtes brûlées sont prêtes à
faire chauffer la gomme leur objectif
sur cette course terminée dans les 300
premiers du classement
pour cela marianne et justin ont une
stratégie alterné leur rôle dans les
dunes c'est moi du coup le pilote et
marianne mako pilote qui va me guider
tout au long des quatre jours en vrai on
va autant conduire l'une et l'autre mais
comme c'était moi qui avais proposé 4 l
trophy je me suis mis en tant que pilote
mais officiellement la tuque les deux
pilotes prochaine arrêts pour les deux
plaisirs oise le 20 février prochain ils
devront se rendre au village départ à
biarritz avec leur 4l rose pour une
dernière vérification technique avant le
grand départ
le retour est lui prévu le 3 mars avec
des souvenirs à plein la tête
ce journal qui n'est pas terminé on fait
tout de suite un tour dans nos salles de
cinéma saint-quentinoise c'est au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret je
vous propose un événement exceptionnel
donc ce samedi à 14 heures ça commence
par une projection avec un programme de
courts métrages liberté 13 films poème
c'est la collection sortant de l'école
donc qui a déjà produit des les
programmes sur des poésies
donc voilà c'est des films poèmes et là
c'est sur la poésie de paul eluard donc
13 13 courts métrages pour treize jeunes
réalisateurs issus des écoles
d'animation
voilà nous qui met vraiment en avant la
poésie du des lois rejault joue avec
avec plein de techniques d'animation
différentes et plein de ton aussi devant
la de récits très différent très variés
et c'est l'occasion d'accueillir une
peau est donc la poète passe quatre
petits qui vient nous proposer un
atelier d'écriture de poésie etc offerts
par les itinéraires poétique
donc c'est accessible à partir de 6 7
ans et c'est aussi pour les adultes
donc n'hésitez pas et en plus vous aurez
un goûter donc ce samedi à 14 heures à
l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]
ça y est c'est la fin de ce journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]